يعادل تاثيره تاثيرا انفجار قنبله نوويه
سيؤدي الى عواقب بيئيه واقتصاديه
وتكنولوجيه ضخمه وخلال اربعه ايام ستغمر
المياه المنطقه برمتها لاجل ذلك يجب اجلاء
المدنيين والحيوانات باسرع وقت ممكن لتجنب
الكارثه بعد تدمير اربعه توربينات في محطه
نوفا كخوفكا جنوب اوكرانيا وارتفاع منسوب
المياه الى عشره امتار هذه الكارثه ستؤدي
الى نقص المياه في خزان نوفا كخوفكا مما
سيؤدي الى جفاف الحقول في جنوب اوكرانيا
كما ان عشرات المصانع الكبرى ستتوقف عن
العمل بسبب قله المياه وانقطاع الكهرباء
مما سيؤدي الى عواقب بالغه في المنطقه
محاسن حداره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات